Monday September 4th 1992. dear diary as
of noon today I'm officially running for
class president of Delta
secondary Dante little legs running on a
more pizza for lunch platform
Stephen trillo buy it trillo is
running on an expanded shorts not just
on Fridays anymore platform
Tabitha mordreds running on PE should be
an elective platform Ah that's a good
one I can't say I disagree combo
toddler's running on a
pipe dream pop quiz band plan platform
good luck combo gentleman tenders
running on a make math an official
School sport platform some contenders in
the mix to be sure but as always nobody
stands a chance against
Jibber prevailia